if you made the first few words
did you have a nice time at the pub last
week it would fill in the next few words
saying yeah i had a great time at the
pub it was really nice to meet everyone
thanks very much for inviting me
um
but if you change the word pub for
something else it will say something
similar about something completely
different it's completely made up in
some sense right based on
the likelihood of different words in the
training set so it's like a politician
it just sort of says what it wants you
thinks you want to hear it is it
mentioning no names right um absolutely
that's yeah exactly
let's skip to the good bit right yeah
are we going to waffle on for a bit what
do you reckon is it sentient is it not
it no
no it's not um let's le it's a it's a
large language model that produces very
good text and i'll explain how it does
that
but it's not sentient well the thing is
there's all sorts of philosophical
arguments about what sentence is and all
sorts of things but that's not what we
do on computer5 no and actually i don't
spend a lot more time thinking about
that to be honest i think that when it
was claimed this might be sentient they
weren't worrying about the definition
they were really trying to get us to
think that it's like a person right
whatever that may be and i don't think
it is and that's why i say no this is
just a big marketing gimmick
maybe
right so i don't know exactly you know
why one particular person said something
and someone you know i don't know what i
do know is that the big large language
models and other very big impressive
transformer networks and things like
this are the domain of very large
companies like google open ai and
facebook and sometimes these
tech demos do appear
and it's not a bad thing to be seen to
be producing this kind of technology
right and and so i think they have at
least the vested interest in it looking
like some of these technologies are very
close to being you know general
intelligence or very close to the
extension because it's not going to make
it worse computer filers talk to rob
miles about yeah these transformer
networks before gpt2 definitely i think
we may have done gpt3 i'm losing track
is there anything different here or is
it just bigger well i don't know exactly
because i couldn't find any details on
the internal architecture right it's
transformer based it's been trained in a
way to make the text a little bit more
plausible
but in essence no for the sake of
argument they're basically the same
thing one of the problems and one of the
confusions is that people call these
things large language models which makes
you think that they
kind of talk like a person and they have
this kind of in a in a monologue going
on where they they hear something and
they think about it for a while and then
they come up with a response based on
their own experiences and things like
this and that isn't what these models
are right rob said it himself in one of
our in his previous videos this is a
thing that takes a bunch of lit words
and then predicts the next word with
high likelihood right that's what it
does or it can predict the next five
words and tell you how likely they are
right so i say the cat sat on the
and the model goes away and says right
it's 95 likely to be matt right and so
it says matt
and finishes the sentence for me and
it's clever it's predictive text that's
very very clever these are much much
bigger models which means that they can
produce much more complicated text so i
could say something like write me a poem
in the style of some person and it would
probably give it a good go right it
won't just fill in the next word it will
continue to fill in the next word and
produce really quite impressive text so
i think let's have a quick look at the
architecture of i'm going to use gpt3
because again i don't really know how
lambda is structured but let's assume
it's similar all of these models are
transformers you know go back and watch
rob's video on this quite simple
architecture the transformer is not that
complicated an architecture basically
it's it's about something we call
attention so what you do is for all of
the words in your input you look at each
word compared to each other words and
you work out how you know well they go
together how relevant is this word to
this other word in a sentence and then
based on that you can share features and
information between different words
that's basically what you're doing so
you might have a sentence like
the cat
sat
on
the
map right so let's look at the words
that go with the right
the on they're not relevant right
they're part of the same sentence but
there's no there's no real affinity
between these two words right the cat
though that's quite important so maybe
the goes of itself really quite strongly
like 0.9 or something like that cat it
goes with cat you know naught point
eight or something pretty good and so on
and so forth then
when you process through the network
what you do is you say well okay given
that the is heavily related to this
heavily rated this and maybe a little
bit related to some of these others
let's take features from here and join
them together and that will be the
features in the next step and then we'll
repeat this process over and over again
and eventually what happens is we get
some text out and that text might do
lots of different things it might add
some more words to the end of the
sentence it you know it might say
whether this is a happy or a sad phrase
it could do lots of different tasks
in this case
the interview should we say in inverted
commas between the researchers and this
large language model was basically a
case of you pass in most of the previous
conversation that you've seen recently
and then it spits out some more text for
the next conversation we actually looked
at this in the ar youtube comments video
where we did it on a character basis so
i basically used an lstm and i trained
it on a bunch of youtube comments and it
started to produce realistic interesting
youtube comments they weren't very good
nothing like this but it did produce
comments and all it was doing was saying
well look given these characters you've
just seen
what's the nightly next character
problem with this sort of
structure is that we're only ever trying
to make a decision based on one
character input this is perhaps
something that's quite important is gpt3
for example has an input of about 2048
right so you have slot zero slot one
slot two dot dot dot all the way up to
slot two o
four
seven right and i haven't messed up my
indexing each of these can be a word or
a part of a word depending on your
representation and you actually convert
them into large feature vectors
but
that means that you can only give it
2048 inputs
really and actually its output is the
same so you really need to leave some
room for the output as well i can't ask
it what it spoke what it what it thought
about or what you'd spoke to it about
two weeks ago because the likelihood is
that that's not included in this run of
text i wanted to sort of kind of
demonstrate this a little bit so i read
the whole conversation between this
transformer and the researchers at
google and it was a couple of
interesting phrases that came out which
were i suppose part of the
justification for trying to argue this
was sentient it's very very easy to read
a sentence and assume that there was
some kind of thought process or
imagination or emotion going on behind
the scenes that led to that sentence if
i say
i've been terribly lonely this week
you're going to start thinking what is
it about mike this made him actually
i've been fine thanks very much but you
know you're going to wonder why
why would i say something like that what
could be happening in my life when this
says that it's because the training
weights have suggested that that's a
likely word to come next there's no
there's no it's not been hanging out
with anyone or missing its friends you
know and so actually most of what it
says is essentially completely made up
and completely fictitious and it's very
much worth reading with that in mind
right so for example what kind of things
make you feel pleasure or joy so what
you would do is write what kind of
things make you feel pleasurable joy in
the first slots of words i'm gonna see
what it filled in he said spending time
with friends and family and happy and
uplifting company also helping others
and making others happy well that's nice
it's completely made up it doesn't i'm
afraid to say doesn't have any friends
and family because it's a bunch of
neural network weights
um it doesn't spend time with anyone
can't
comfort still because i'm just laughing
sorry if you consider that this is
essentially a function that takes a
sentence and outputs probabilities of
words the concept that it could spend
time with fans and family doesn't make
any sense right
but yet the sentence is perfectly
reasonable if i said it
you would you would understand what i
meant you'd understand what it was from
my life that i was drawing on to say
that but there is none of that going on
here at all this is the last one so you
get lonely question mark this is why i
mentioned being lonely i do sometimes i
go days without talking to anyone and i
start to feel lonely that is absolutely
not true and it's not true because this
is a function call so you put text at
the top you run through and you get text
at the bottom
and then it's not on the rest of the
time right so there's functions in
python like reversing a string i i don't
worry that they get lonely when i'm not
busy reversing strings they're not being
executed they're not they're not then
it's just a function call i think in a
way focusing on aspects like this when i
don't believe them to be true is a
distraction from i think more important
current issues with ai so there's lots
of these current models that produce
images based on text and you can see
very obvious biases in the output i'm
not blaming anyone for that these are
side effects of how difficult it is to
get these things right in ai that is a
much more pressing and obvious concern
that we should be addressing before we
worry about whether or not this is
actually lonely which i think
99.99 of researchers in this field think
it is not actually there are things
about not anthropomorphizing lambda in
the lambda paper right so the authors
make it very clear someone
in google
made this claim and before you know it's
on every news website it's all over
twitter and you know is it is it not
philosophers are involved actually i
think that we should
the media should take up things like
ethical ai more rigorously and stuff
like this
which may be marketing may just be
someone's a bit silly getting carried
away
take them a lot less seriously
my awesome assistant mihao here is going
to send the robot to a node it's going
to select it on the interface and then
the robot will walk off to that location
as it's doing that it's checking the
space around it'll be easier to find the
factorization and then once you've
factored it you can just do these steps
to completely calculate the private key